shane bieber is going to be on the mound
tonight
he will be the nissan starting pitcher
for the tribe bieber just an outstanding
year 8-1 he'll make his second start
against the white sox this year he had a
no decision uh
back in uh at chicago on the ninth of
august uh but he pitched a good ball
game they ended up winning that game tim
anderson will lead it off
got him looking at a fastball
low heater right at the bottom of the
zone
and that is strikeout number 113 for
shane bieber well just a perfect pitch
down at the knees
on the outside edge let's take a look at
lucas giolito on for the 12th time he's
looking for his fifth win his era about
three and a half
86 strikeouts and 66 inning that jumps
out at you left-handers haven't hit him
very well in fact opponents are just
183. frankie lindor switch hitter
banning left-handed and that just missed
actually it looked like it should have
been called strike three instead it's
ball four so lindor's abort and that'll
bring up jose ramirez switch it or
batting left-handed one-two that's on
the ground fielded nicely there by
abraham he'll tag the bag at first and
throw it a second for the tag play and
it's in time this is a great job to not
only stop him that ball was by him
that's a terrific play that ball gets
behind that's a double lucas giallito
facing santana the cleanup hitter swung
on and hammered high
deep to right way out of here carlos
santana with a moon shot to right it's
number seven for santana and the indians
leading one to nothing well an inside
heater to carlos and he did not miss it
well that's good to see him do it from
this side of the floor yeah right look
at it he's excited about it frankie
lindor with a single to right perez is
at second cesar hernandez
switch interventing left-handed round
ball they might turn to let's see
there's one and
hernandez is able to beat it out big the
bobble by anderson
cost him the double play yes it did he
didn't field it cleanly giolito has
really labored here in the third he has
walked his second in this game carlos
santana who walloped the solo homer to
right last inning will matt with the
bases loaded got him on a slider in the
dirt and the inning has come to an end
big strikeout right there for lucas
gilito in the white sox as the indians
leave them loaded so the tying run gets
to third the go-ahead run gets second
base here's encarnacion that one hit on
the ground left side will be fielded by
lynn doris thought about third does not
throw there throws across the diamond
instead and the runs gonna score jose
abreu will cross home plate and the
white sox have tied it here
on a ground out by incarnation it's 1-1
in the fourth first and third for
abraham here with two outs a 1-1
baseball game the one man the white sox
won up there with the game on the line
swinging amazing he struck him out what
a job by shane bieber one run unearned
he allowed two hits struck out ten in
five innings and walked three and shane
beaver in his final regular season start
getting lots of congratulations in that
dugout phil this is a game we expected
to see these two starters locking [ __ ]
and getting after it they have both been
outstanding in the air left field
backing up on that one a couple of steps
says jimenez he'll make the catch inning
over one two three go the indians here
in the fifth we're through five toledo
with nine strikeouts cesar hernandez
will start things off that strike three
of fastball he heated him up for ten
strikeouts tonight third time this year
that pitching opponents have banned 10
or more in a major league game and now
the indians have runners at second and
third one out ron mio reyes has struck
out swinging and looking and boy do the
indians need him to put the ball in play
in the air center field plenty deep
enough
great job by reyes on a 1-2 pitch here
comes ramirez 2-1 cleveland rbi number
34 reyes garrett crochet comes on
for the fourth time he throws rockets
we'll see if he gets him in the zone he
has lately swinging a miss strike three
outside at 100 miles an hour strikeout
for garrett crochet and he struck him
out there so crochet has carved once
again in the first two batters
james karen jack on the pitch for the
indians mid-90s heater and that good
power curve ball
karen jack's 26th outing he's owed two
three saves and now the white sox with
an opportunity to tie the game as jose
abreu steps in that's a line shot into
center field mercado had to adjust he
makes the catch tagging from third on
his way to the plate to tie this game
it's moncotta it's 2-2 jose abreu with
number 57 on the rbi tally and here in
the eighth a brand new ball game all
tied at two game tied at two as we're in
the bottom of the eighth inning
hernandez oh for three tonight on the
ground right side diving stop there by
abreu gets up and flips it over to hoyer
covering the bag in time well he's been
playing close to a gold glove first base
all year long i mean he has been
phenomenal now the 2-0
in the hole
lindor got
that's about as close as you can get
bang bang playing i think it's worth the
challenge oh we got him wow wow there
you go
and he can't believe it engel is stunned
that'll bring up jordan luplow three
strikeouts tonight swung out and blasted
deep left field go on to the home run
porch
it's another walk-off win for the
indians
they're second in a row
[Music]
with the second home run of the year
as they beat the sax by a final score of
3-2